هل هناك همم بالفعل همم احتماليه تكون هذه
الصواريخ روسيه بالنظر الى همم نطاق
العمليات العسكريه الجاريه في الارض خاصه
اننا نتحدث عن بلده في مقاطعه على الحدود
مع اوكرانيا
المعلومات صحيحه متحدث الانتاج ولم يقدم
تفصيلات كبيره لهذا السبب همم الصوره
ضبابيه لكن نتحدث الان في مجال الاحتمالات
والاحتمالات هذه تعتمد على امور عديده
الان همم في هذا اليوم هناك هجوم بعض
التقارير تحدثت عن 100 صاروخ وبعض
التقارير تحدثت عن 90 صاروخ
اسم منها وصل الى منطقه نيفين هل احد هل
هناك صواريخ ظلت طريقه وسقطت داخل الحدود
البولنديه وكم المسافه من الحدود
البولنديه او من اي من اقرب هدف عسكري او
منشاه حيويه داخل اوكرانيا انا الان اتحدث
بصوره نظريه قبل الوصول الى همم الفحص
الفني الدقيق الذي سيحدد نوع الصاروخ الذي
سقر لانه اي عمليه كشف من قبل الخبراء
ستحدد هل هو صاروخ اسكندر هل هو كنجال او
هو هو غيره من الصواريخ هناك الصواريخ من
ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي موجوده في الجانب
الاخراني اقصد صواريخ ضد الجو 300 هل
الصاروخ اللي سرقه 300 اذا كان ذلك فهنا
نذهب باتجاه ان احتماليه ان قلت لك من
اوكرانيا اذا دعيني اقول حتى هذه اللحظه
لا توجد معلومات دقيقه يقنيه توجه الاتهام
نحن امام همم احتمالات مفتوحه اذا كان سقط
على مقربه من الحدود قد يكون هذا الصاروخ
اما صاروخ همم روسي ظل طريقه وهذا الامر
اعتدنا عليه في ايام القصر سوريا عندما
يتم قصف صواريخ من بحر قزوين بعض اذا كان
يقع على بعد 40 كانوا متر من الهدف وبعضها
سقط في العراق وبعضها سقط في ايران اذا
داعيني اقول لا يسال من المبكر ان نقول ان
همم من اين اتى هذا الصوت لكن احتمالات
الان هذا الصاروخ قد يكون صاروخ روسي من
جمله الصواريخ التي اطلقت في هذا اليوم
الاحتمال الاخر ان يكون صاروخ
يعود الى وحدات الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه
التي تتصدى للصواريخ الروسيه وبالتالي لا
نستطيع ان نحدد الان ما لم يكون هناك فحص
دقيق من قبل خبراء يحدد نوع هذا الصاروخ
لكن على جميع الاحتمالات يعتبر حدث غير
طبيعي ان تسقط صواريخ داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولكن مكان الصاروخ مكان سقوط
الصاروخ هو الذي يجسد رد الفعل
شرطه الى انه قد حدث فيما سبق في هذه
الحرب ان ضل صاروخ روسي طريقه نسبه الخطا
هنا هل يمكن ان نعتبرها عاليه فيما يتعلق
بالصواريخ يتم توجيهات داخل اوكرانيا
حسب انواع الصواريخ حسب انواع الصواريخ
دائما المتحدث باسم همم للجيش الروسي
صواريخ فرض صوتيه عاليه الدقه لكن بعض
التقارير قراتها وقد لا يتم الاخذ بها
بالمطلق ان نسبه الخطا تشمل في بعض
الحالات الى 60% هذه في بعض التقارير ولا
اتبناه لكنها ورد هناك درجه خطا كبير في
الاسلحه الروسيه خاصه الاسلحه القديمه
التي تعود الى الحقبه السوفيتي الان عندما
نتحدث عن صاروخ صارمه لا اتحدث عن صواريخ
احتماليه الخطا قليله جدا لكن صار ما
يستخدم يستخدم
سوده ليست 100% لماذا قد يحدث خلل فني في
نفس الصاروخ او او في هذه التوجيهروف طيب
اليوم كنا بالاساس نتعامل ايضا مع حوالي
100 صاروخ روسي وجهها لكيف اخر كيف
وكان هناك اذا حديث عن قصف صاروخي وضربه
صاروخيه هي الاكبر بالنسبه همم لروسيا في
ضمن هذه الحرب ولكن هل تعتقد ان في حسابات
روسيا ان توسي على ضربتين من مصلحتها ان
اتصل صواريخها الى خارج شكرا
يعني ليس من مصلحتها ان تتعدى صواريخها
منطقه العمليه اما فيما يتعلق بالا ال 100
صاروخ والهجمه الصاروخيه الاكبر منذ بدء
الحرب يعني علينا ان نعود تقريبا اكثر من
شهرين ونركب تسلسل الاحداث
وانت قدمتي كثير من البرامج التي تتعلق
فيما ال ال التناوله اذا عدنا كل حدث على
ارض المعركه رئيسي ومؤلم لروسيا كان الرد
عليه بتوسيع دائره القصص الصاروخي بعد
الانسحاب من كيف كان هناك توسع في
الاستخدام بعد بعد الانسحاب من خارج كيف
كان هناك توسع بعد الهجوم على بالرود كانه
هناك توسع بعد قصف جسر كرش كان هناك توسع
بعد قصه بيل كان هناك توسع اليوم في هذا
اليوم
انا هناك انسحاب من خلسن فيعتبر همم ضربه
او طعنه لكرامه الجيش الروسي سيكون توسع
هناك مؤتمر العشرين ومحاوله ادانه روسيا
في بال في
بال في همم في اندونيسيا وبالتالي رفض
وزير الخارجيه ويمكن ان تكون الرساله
مزدوجه يعني ما جرى اليوم رساله مزدوجه
ردا على ما جرى في قرش ورد على الموقف
الجيت 20 همم في في بالي من حيث محاوله
ادانت روسيا فهي حاولت ان ترد وتقول
انني سائر في عمليات العسكريه لدي اوراق
قوه لما تستخدمه ودعيني اربط ما جرى في
جمله واحده يا عيني اربط ما جرى في هذا
التوسع باستهداء همم
المنشات الحيويه والكهربائيه وترك سبع
ملايين منزل بدون همم
كهرباء بحديث الرئيس الروسي السابق
ماذا قال هناك اسلحه لم نستخدمها وهناك
اهداف لم نتناولها اذا هي ترجمه لما قاله
الرئيس السابق ورد على
خساره خرسن ورد على جيت 20
بالياء فايزه